after the rose-garden event the
president flew to New York City for the
first time since his inauguration
protestors were there to greet him the
president came to New York to meet
Australian Prime Minister Malcolm
Turnbull they clashed on the telephone a
few months ago the two leaders spoke on
the USS Intrepid a world war two
aircraft that is now a museum from there
the president headed to trump National
Golf Club in Bedminster New Jersey for a
long weekend Margaret Brennan is nearby
branch burg Marga good morning good
morning well the president is waking up
at his private club in New Jersey after
a busy Thursday capped off by an evening
spent mending fences with Australia one
of America's closest military and
intelligence sharing partners our brave
warriors have fought shoulder to
shoulder in every major conflict at a
black-tie dinner aboard a decommissioned
aircraft carrier president Trump's
celebrated the 75th anniversary of a key
World War two victory by US and
Australian forces Americans have had no
better friends than the Australians the
first face-to-face meeting with
Australian Prime Minister Malcolm
Turnbull was also a chance to reset
their relationship after a tense
February phone call very cool you guys
exaggerated that call that was a big
exaggeration I would say we had a great
call I mean we're not babies during that
initial conversation President Trump was
angered to learn of an Obama era deal to
take in more than 1,200 refugees from
Australia he publicly blasted the
agreement as dumb last month vice
president pence assured Turnbull that
the US would stand by the deal clear
that will honor the agreement doesn't
mean we admire the agreement earlier
Thursday mr. Trump declared support for
religious tolerance at the signing of a
related executive order we will never
ever stand for religious discrimination
never ever but in March the federal
courts suspended the president's travel
ban on six muslim-majority nations
citing quote a purpose to disfavor a
particular religion the courts pointed
these comments from the campaign Donald
J Trump is calling for a total and
complete shutdown of Muslims entering
the United States notably the president
has chosen Saudi Arabia home to two of
Islam's holiest sites as the first stop
and his inaugural foreign trip this
month then it's on to Israel and Gayle
he'll get to meet the Pope at the
Vatican all right a lot of people want
to meet the Pope thank you very much
Margaret